what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
actually recording in a different audio
space so let me know if you guys hear a
difference at all i'm kind of curious
but uh we're picking back up with
invincible and this one basically deal
this is kind of interesting this deals
with
a huge change to the invincible mythos
based on what we've known
so far right so what this initially does
or what i want to do here is i want to
start out where you end up
having cecil having a conversation with
invincible's mom and the funny thing
about this
is that deborah had largely kept the
existence of
omni kid or kid omni man or whatever you
want to call him had largely kept him a
secret from cecil this was done for a
couple different reasons the first is
because of the fact that one she just
doesn't trust him right that's pretty
straightforward
based on her experiences dealing with
with nolan and so on and so forth and
the fact that he's just he's a
government agent and the second thing is
because she's taken this kid to race so
in a lot of ways
she looks at him as this young boy that
she needs to take care of on her own
and keep him as safe as she possibly can
and that's why when cecil shows up here
and starts talking about a kind of
disappointment about the fact that she
didn't tell him what was going on and
all that kind of stuff at the end of the
day her response is you're not taking my
kid and that's the thing about cecil is
this kind of response and in turn is
well we're not really looking to take
him but it's important you understand
that after everything that happened with
your husband
we are a little weary about him having a
child outside of mark and then in turn
that child's showing up here we have no
idea what this kid is capable of
now from there he kind of gets a call
where things are basically popping off
and going belly up and then you switch
over to mark meeting with eve now one of
the things we talked about in the
previous videos
is that mark's whole romantic interest
in eve is predicated on a couple
different things one
she's hot and they're young right need i
say more
two when mark had his escapades where he
was kind of running around
and dealing with really kind of being
thrown through time and so on that when
he encountered the future version of eve
she begged him tell me something right
like tell my past self what's going on
whether we're gonna date or not gonna
date whether you love me you don't love
me but tell me something which really
showed this idea that eve was very much
interested in mark
but because she never got a definitive
answer she never moved on she just
stayed hung up on him forever so the
important thing here
is that mark had a kind of conversation
with her where he told her that he soon
be interested but when she asked where
it was coming from he revealed the truth
and eve took that personally because it
didn't really feel like he was
confessing feelings to her
because he actually had feelings for it
seemed like he was doing it because he
didn't want her to become the future
version that he saw
which really kind of equates to like a
pity date that's really kind of what it
came across as then of course
nobody wants to be a pity date and so
ultimately she kind of took it
personally now the fact that she's
receptive to having conversations with
him and talking to him and the fact that
she's like
flying with him you know they're kind of
going off on superhero stuff really
indicates that okay sure like at the
very least she wants to spend time with
him otherwise she would just fly there
on her own
right so obviously there's there's some
kind of interest there and so once they
get to this location
whereby cecil had sent them the
revelation of basically all the
guardians of the globe who had
essentially gone missing
are down about three miles below and so
once mork gets down there what we end up
learning is that doc
seismic had basically kidnapped all of
them now the important thing about doc
seismic here's the thing about this guy
this guy's basically a stand-in for the
mole man right fools you guys who don't
know who the mole man is in marvel
comics he leads the melody
he's not important never really was
he was kind of a throwaway character in
a lot of different ways and that's one
of the things that kind of gets tossed
out here right is that
nobody really seems to take him
seriously but the fact that he was able
to essentially capture all the
superheroes from around the world
is a pretty big achievement right it's
no small thing now of course mark comes
into the rescue and that basically
offers a momentary distraction which in
turn allows all you know all the various
heroes to escape but then like giant
lava monsters things like that start
popping up so not really anything crazy
and out of the ordinary the big
important thing here this is a
significant thing
is that in this moment when mark is
seemingly defeated
by the forces of dox seismic that you
end up having cecil who basically sends
in what he calls
a secondary team and this secondary team
comes in a couple of different forms the
first bit here comes in the form of the
rihanna men which pretty much all of you
guys know
by by the tv show right like the people
who were essentially turned into like
robotic
kind of cyborg things by d.a sinclair
and the second one comes in the form of
dark wing 2. now here's the thing
as we know d.a sinclair is working with
cecil right that's one of the things
that we saw in the previous video that
we did
that in the aftermath of d.a sinclair
doing what he'd done
he was supposed to stand trial and so on
and so forth and instead had been
offered a deal by cecil we knew that
mark does not but dark wing 2 is a
little more interesting since you guys
know dark wing was part of the original
guardians of the globe who were
basically killed by nolan by omni man
before he fled earth this
is essentially his robin more or less
the big difference here is that midnight
city is largely where they operate right
so kirkman's not even trying to hide the
illusions
between darkwing and batman right
they're more or less the same thing the
big issue here though is that darkwing
snapped because of how extreme
midnight city was and because there was
so much incredible crime there and so
what he ended up doing was basically
killing anybody who committed any crime
it didn't matter what that crime was
from small things all the way to big
things
so the fact that he's here is kind of a
crazy situation because mark's not a
huge fan of this guy and in fact one of
the things that actually goes on
is that where dr seismic is doing all
these crazy things and so on and so
forth
that dark wing actually ends up leading
him or at least pulling him down into a
crevasse which more or less seems to
kill him and the response of mark is he
immediately freaks out right calls him a
murderer and starts pummeling the sky
now the big thing about this
is that mark was the only one who
witnessed what it was that darkwing was
doing in midnight city and so for
everybody here who's watching mark doing
what he's doing at the end of the day
they see it as one of these things where
he's basically losing his mind
but from mark's perspective this guy's
crazy he's psychotic he has no business
being any kind of a superhero whatsoever
he will always engage in extremely
violent actions if he can get away with
it now the experience was or really
everything that was kind of happening
was technically documented and mark
actually goes as far as to say that like
you guys had to have seen it it was on
the news and
recorded and all that kind of stuff but
there's actually a little more
you know craziness going afoot instead
what ends up happening is cecil steps in
tells mark to stand down things kind of
pop off he tells mark we'll talk about
this later
and in turn mark has a bit of a
conversation with eve not a whole lot
going on there really just kind of
talking about how like he knows the
whole thing with him in darkwing was
essentially recorded it should have been
on the news all that kind of stuff but
it wasn't people don't know about it
which means that it seems to have been
hidden
and he really seems to believe that
cecil was the one who did it and so
flying directly off to encounter cecil
directly as the two of them are talking
d.a sinclair walks out and that's when
mark comes to the realization
this guy's working with d.a sinclair in
a pretty quick
situation we're basically given this
revelation on behalf of mark
that nothing cecil's telling him has
really been true that cecil's basically
been lying all this time and so one of
the things that happens is that cecil
basically leads him into the white room
as you guys know that white room is
basically designed in such a way to
where it's skews with or really messes
with eyesight
so that those people who are in it can't
actually see what's in there right all
they see
is basically white and that's one of the
things mark kind of let let's
loose into cecil right and it's just
like how could you have possibly worked
with somebody like d.a sinclair
knowing the kind of things that he's
done and something has to be going on
here like you had to have gotten rid of
that footage you had to have done
something like you had to have known
what was going on with dark wings so
that now i'm led to believe
that you have a hand in the reason why
no one's aware of what's going on with
darkwing enter
all these rihanna men who had basically
been built for cecil
by d.a sinclair now one of the things
that goes on here mark just
crushes these guys i mean with and in no
uncertain terms it's quite readily these
guys are defeated and it's one of these
things where cecil
almost kind of looks at mark and talks
about like angstrom levy right how mark
had seemingly killed a guy but the
response of mark is that was
unintentional it was not my goal to
murder a person but this guy darkwing
does the same thing this guy d.a
sinclair they do the same thing like
they experimented on people killed
people different things like that like
they're dark and twisted people you
can't take what is basically an accident
and then in turn apply it to the concept
that like it was an intentional killing
of someone that's not really what was
going on and so that's kind of the crazy
thing is because at the end of the day
the stance of cecil is it doesn't matter
right like i've got my hands in
everything and i believe i'm genuinely
doing the right thing if you're not with
me you're against me and that's kind of
the crazy thing here
is because cecil seems to be taking on
this exceedingly dark and and really
absolute standpoint so much so that once
mark overcomes all these rihanna man and
then starts going after cecil cecil
panics takes off and then there's like
maybe like 500 rihanna men who all kind
of exist here and that's when mark's
kind of like okay look like are you
gonna arrest me like what's gonna happen
here
and basically the rihanna men start
turning on mark and then ultimately
cecil activates this kind of sonic
beacon device and what we end up finding
out is that at some point when mark was
given the
kind of earpiece by cecil that it also
had a device inside his body that
basically threw off his equilibrium and
would emit a sonic pulse
and the reason why this was done is
because in his time having and having
dealt with and engaged with omni man
even though they'd worked together for
so long
the reality of season and kind of
looking at the sky was
like equilibrium is a necessary thing
because unlike a person where you gave
them vertigo they would get a little
dizzy and probably have to sit down
but for somebody like mark or somebody
like omniman being able to screw with
equilibrium in their head is a huge deal
because it's necessary to fly the sonic
pulse is almost just
crushing in terms of the sound that it
emits so much so that mark is largely
incapacitated here and that's kind of
the crazy thing because following that
mark actually speeds off right he kind
of asks like like you know how strong
how capable is this pulse and then
speeds off where he actually starts to
outrace it like literally cecil's
teleporting
trying to keep up with him and then
ultimately catches him and then mark
basically lands inside the headquarters
of
the new guardians of the globe right rex
and and all those guys monster girl and
so on and basically brings to their
attention
cecil's the one that's doing all this
and so it's really the first time that
you see people in the superhero
community who are learning that cecil is
always been sus man
there's always been something up with
this guy and that's kind of the crazy
thing is because when he kind of makes
this case that when mark makes this case
that cecil is employing people who are
serial killers or murderers people who
are experimenting on other individuals
somebody like d.a sinclair at the end of
the day it's kind of like
like yeah like the whole thing with with
like darkwing that was recorded
that should have been on the news but
because of the connections that that
cecil had he had it suppressed he had it
he basically made sure that
nobody would know that darkwing was
doing that stuff and he basically
blackmailed him and said that if you
don't work for me directly i'll release
this to the public and the whole world
will know that you're basically a crazy
psychopath and that's how he seems to
basically get people to work for him and
that leads to the rest of the guardians
of the globe
basically going on and confronting cecil
directly and that's where things get
kind of nuts because
in this process and this is incredibly
important in this process
mark begins to lose his control and this
is kind of a dangerous thing here
because as that happens he starts to
become somewhat bloodlusted now the
crazy thing about that is this this is
in
a lot of ways kind of where omniman was
but the big difference between omniman
and mark is that nolan was a guy who'd
lived for
so long that this idea of him just kind
of giving into his emotions was very
rare but mark does not have the
experience and does not have the same
kind of training uh that that omni man
had and so it's much much easier for him
to get into his emotions and so that's
one of the things that kind of happens
is that with everything going on with
mark and this kind of sonic pulse that's
ringing through his head
it's on the verge of killing him and
that's when everybody like everybody's
like you have to shut that thing down
you're gonna kill mark you're gonna kill
invincible and that's not something that
cecil wants on is on his conscience so
ultimately he tells da to basically shut
off the
the sonic emitter and then when mark
gets that chance to kind of recoup
he almost kills cecil of course he
doesn't and then cecil basically fires
him on the spot
and you would think that you know when
when it looks like mark is just kind of
like okay fine we're gonna go ahead and
let that go
mark immediately charges cecil and then
basically says if we're done then that
means we're done that means you and i
have no contact
whatsoever so if you come near my family
my mom my brother or whoever
i will kill you if you send anybody to
my family that i know works on your
behalf or i even get a whiff of the idea
that they work on your behalf i'll come
back and i'll kill you and that's one of
the important
things is because what mark's kind of
demonstrated here is that at the end of
the day despite cecil's best
efforts especially mark knowing this
device is in his brain that was the ace
in the hole right that was the only
thing that cecil really had to overcome
mark
now that that's not there anymore mark
has the ability to get rid of that or
seems to have the ability to get rid of
it then now cecil has nothing over mark
and so if he really does piss him off
mark will kill him and there'll be
nothing cecil can do about it absolutely
nothing at all he's an old man right
what could he possibly hope to do
against somebody like mark having said
that this is uh this is kind of a crazy
thing because
mark has this conversation with eve
right where she kind of hung around
the house you know just kind of keep an
eye and make sure that mark was gonna be
okay when he got back and different
things like that and mark kind of spills
the beans and says you know for a moment
there i thought i was gonna die i guess
that was really the test right for a
moment i thought i was gonna die
and in that moment the only person that
i could think of was you that was you
were the only person i could think of in
the whole wide world and so because of
that i love you like i am i'm i'm with
you like you and me like that's it
now of course you know omni kid sees it
and he's like gross
but it's a it's a funny little thing
there right but following this there's
there's a couple big things that happen
one of the biggest and most notable
things that take place is that mark
takes his younger brother under his wing
to train him now as most of you guys can
probably guess just from having seen
things like star wars and so on this is
not going to end well
mark was as effective of a hero as he is
for a bunch of different reasons the
least of which has
anything to do with the training that he
got from nolan we know that just because
of the experience the two of them had
and didn't really get any measure of
training until his powers developed the
reason why mark is the way he is
is because of the time he spent among
humanity right the the time that he
spent among people who in
almost every conceivable way were weaker
than he was even before he knew that he
had powers he spent all this time among
people
and adopted a lot of human tendencies
both good and bad for somebody like his
younger brother he doesn't have that
right so it's literally a rush job
on training taking this kid that has
these incredible abilities who basically
gained them
you know over a decade before mark did
in terms of age relation and then in
turn
taking him under his wing to be his
trainer the other thing about this is
that because of everything that played
out with mark
and cecil that essentially the guardians
of the globe have split the the team
team's roster as we know it for the most
part it's kind of back to its old self
right in the sense that you've got
monster girl you've got robot who's now
in a boy's body and
and so on and so forth adam eve and
those characters and of course mark as
well and then you have the actual
guardians of the globe so you've got
duplicate you've got the immortal and
and so on but it's one of these things
where it's kind of like okay like
as far as cecil is concerned they're the
official team right the team team
is really more of like a stand-in team
right so it's almost kind of an unspoken
statement or an unspoken phrase that
like they're essentially enemies right
like if the team team steps in
to confront some enemy the guardians of
the globe are going to kill and tries to
stop them then now they're enemies right
they kind of work in that that kind of
weird capacity there the other thing
that goes on here is of course
mark takes his younger brother to meet
the tailor right and then in turn the
tailor also gives mark a new costume
which you know it looks kind of cool you
know
that's that's one of those little
interesting tidbits there but the cool
thing about this
is that you get to this interesting
situation where you basically have this
kind of nuclear silo
that were basically taken over by the
lizard league and of course the wizard
league was kind of a laughable team
but the mauler twins have basically
arrived here to kind of do the same
thing not the exact same thing but to
kind of launch their own plant now this
is going to be one of the most important
parts of the story because one of the
most interesting parts of the story the
way this plays out is that where you
have a conversation between mark and his
brother and the two of them are talking
and
and so on and he's kind of teaching him
the ropes of like when i tell you to
stay you stay
the threats out here are no joke this is
not a kind of time to mess around or
goof off or anything like that you could
get yourself killed facing off against
some of the people
here things along those lines that word
basically reaches the ears of mark that
the mauler twins are attacking this silo
right and when i say word reaches his
ears i mean like he walks into the room
and his mom says like
look at this and so of course he dons
this costume races off to go face off
against the mahler twins who have
basically defeated the guardians of the
globe and so mark does what he can to
step up against them but then when his
brother comes in
and is and he's like where's mark at his
mom's like oh he went to go do this and
then his brother takes off and joins the
joins the fray as well now there's a
huge difference here and there's a huge
moment here
because ultimately mark does what he can
to face off against these guys but a
nuclear weapon is basically launched
right the whole idea of the mauler twins
is to basically take over the computer
systems of the world but at the end of
the day like this nuclear missile is
launched which is really designed as a
kind of uh distraction to get mark out
of the scene and then in turn allow them
to complete their goal but they're
totally unaware of his younger brother
stepping in now as soon as he shows up
he kind of punches one of the mahler
twins in the mouth right they don't
really take him seriously they throw him
into
uh into a wall the kid emerges from
rubble and then just kind of like flies
right through one of them
and kills him this freaks out the other
one right because there's this kind of
unwritten rule
among the superheroes like you don't
kill your villains right it's one of
these things where the villains are kind
of like i mean you know you know how it
is like we do crime you arrest us you
take us to jail and then we get out and
then we do crime again and it's one of
these things where literally one of the
twins is like i give up i surrender like
please just don't hurt me and omni kids
just like you're gonna make it easy for
me huh and then just like punches
punches his brains out through the top
of his head now immortal emerges and
sees all this happening and then omni
kid is like it was an accident right it
was it was an accident and this leads to
mark returning and then cecil arriving
at the same time and as soon as mark
sees cecil
he immediately goes in for the hit right
it's just like i told you to stay away
from my family and that's when cecil is
like no we were here to clean up your
brother's mess
and realizing what it is that his
younger brother had done the two of them
fly into space this is one of the
coolest conversations that we see
because
ultimately he tells his younger brother
he was like he's like you killed those
guys
and his younger brother's like yeah they
were bad guys like they killed people
down there i killed them
now they can't kill anybody else you
should be happy now this
is sound logic right like they've killed
people they've demonstrated
incorrigibility they will always kill
innocent people as long as it allows
them to to achieve their goal and so the
only logical way to
save lives is to kill those guys right
because the important thing about this
and the big takeaway from that is
mark is sacrificing innocent lies to
maintain his own personal morality other
people's lives
are not as important to him as he is to
himself and that's the crazy thing it's
one of the things about superheroes
nobody ever considers that
the the kind of almost narcissistic and
psychopathic nature of what it means to
be hero
i and my morality are what are most
important to me and therefore i will
sacrifice innocent lives
in order to maintain that the stance of
his son is that doesn't make any sense
right like if our job is to save people
and to keep people protected
then we should kill the bad guys
especially if we know the bad guys are
going to routinely kill people
and that's one of the things that he
says you know when mark kind of goes on
this little bit of a speech and he's
like there are laws
and rules and we can't just take that
kind of responsibility for someone
else's life for for taking anybody's
life we're not infallible
what if we're wrong and we kill somebody
innocent well then what then and he says
human life is a precious thing the
response of his brother is
no it's not and mark's kind of kind of
shocked by that and his brother's like
precious
human life is not precious not in
general not everyone
people risk their lives every day they
kill each other if they don't think
their lives are important
why should i most of them are utterly
insignificant
and mark's response is you sound like
that and then his brother's response
here is so why is that bad
why is he so wrong that anything he said
makes sense to you even on a small level
have you ever thought that maybe
our father was right and that is a
mind-blowing moment from from this from
this kid is because at the end of the
day
nolan was right right if humanity really
wanted to fix itself it already would
have it would have been on the road to
doing that but at the end of the day
people do terrible things to each other
and other people stand by and watch it
happen
and so humanity as far as nolan is
concerned and as far as this kid's
concern and at some level as far as i'm
concerned i wouldn't say is a lost cause
but is certainly on its death now right
and so at the end of the day it's kind
of like humanity needs to be made to be
better
even if they don't want to be and if
that means killing criminals in order to
save innocent people then i will do what
the average person is unwilling to do i
will do what you are not willing to do
it's kind of a
it's an amazing philosophy and it's cool
to see it actually said in a comic book
because it makes so much logical sense
it makes so much reasonable sense there
that's why i love the philosophy of like
superheroes doing superhero things and
so on and so forth because
at the end of the day if you're a
superhero how many innocent lives are
you really willing to sacrifice
because you don't like the idea of
killing bad guys right like how many
how many innocent people would you
sacrifice 100 lives would you sacrifice
500 lives well i mean is that just the
price you pay to maintain your role as a
superhero to keep that high morality
when do you draw the line
right that's that's the that's the crazy
thing about about superheroes that's
what makes it so interesting so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later peace